hey man this big X plug man y make sure
y tap in the Bole K show me Ro young
Hood Bole K man you don't want to miss
it let's go hey before we get into the
interview we want to give a shout out to
our family over at Imperial extraction
they're bringing you today's episode um
and check this out if you want a free 2
G thca loaded pre-roll yes that's right
you can get one of these for free you
don't have to buy anything all you got
to do is go to Imperial extraction.
comom use the promo code bootleg and
they're going to send you one of these
for free look premium glass tip one more
time Imperial extraction. comom promo
code bootleg you're going to get a free
2 G THC Diamond loaded pre-roll that's 1
and 12 gram of that premium top shell
flower and a half a gram of THC diamonds
loaded up to your door for free just pay
shipping let's get into the
interview ble Kev show special guest
multiple
yes big X the plug Rama I'm going to let
you introduce your new artist introduce
yourself man for the people yeah on Hood
man it's the beig man y know what the
[__] going
on N
nit on
the oh man big X you my my most listened
to artist on Spotify this year did you
see that when I did the recap I did see
that it was like you and jelly roll and
uh I don't even know who else but but
yeah man [__] congrats on this new
record this new record is going crazy I
saw you first of all this the first time
you hit the Billboard 100 right the yeah
a record yeah I didn't hit the he heat
secret one right right but I'm talking
about like the top 100 songs in the
country yeah yeah I think it's like 60
64 right now something like yeah
congrats how's that feel you know I be I
be knowing what none of this [__] really
mean I just be I'm working I just work
y'all been working non-stop for feel
like a year and a half album Dro Deluxe
album drop tour tour happens we did
three tours it's just going crazy like I
got to see you guys in your live show uh
when you guys hit LA and it was
definitely a Vibe man um have you had
any opportunity to like take a break
relax a little and smell the flowers no
no but it's like this what we asked for
so we ain't complaining about it that's
what I tell everybody cuz I be stressed
all the time yeah cuz I got all kinds of
businesses the podcast the radio show
and I always just say hey man heavy
heavy is the crown man this what I asked
for got to take care of all this back
home but you constantly on the road it's
it's it's it's it's work but like I said
it's what we signed up for I just had a
conversation with uh my boy from Warner
Records and he was like yo every week we
have a meeting about this nle record
that's streaming like crazy and uh and
every nobody in these meetings except me
knows who big X the plug in what and I'm
like what who's in these [__]
meetings but that record is like doing
really [__] well my yes big shout out
to Le Chopper man I don't even know I
don't know where he got my number from
but he called me one day and was just
like hey I heard you going
crazy I'm trying to get you on something
he sent it I ran it and super nice guy
yeah yeah know he cool he cool he called
me after it Dro was like you know
whatever you need let me know any tours
you got I need to pop up on just let me
know I got you so yeah we definitely we
locked in we shout out to n like I said
I'm about to say it's got to be like uh
at this moment in time very very um your
inbox has got to be booming for features
for people trying to work with you I
mean yeah and for like for a short
period of time that it was cool but like
now it's like I don't want to overdo
myself so I'm not doing every feature no
more cuz it's like it's got to be the
[__] that makes sense [__] you want
exactly exactly so yeah but yeah if it
was good it was good the get was good
why it was but no we we we we trying to
preserve oursel we trying to be in it
for a little minute we don't want to so
you guys are the Shaq and Kobe obviously
sha and Kobe right yeah why not the Dirk
and kid or the you know what the Luca
Kyrie you're right we are the Dirk and
who you say Jason kid made me who else
was on the Mavericks back then on that
ring team J Jason Terry no he didn't
stop it was more than it was more than
two people though who was on the
Mavericks in 2011 it was kid whoa whoa
whoa whoa Jason kid somebody say Sean
Mir and I don't want to had a shot
somebody else can had a shot he call hey
no but his shot he was on the
Suns oh t i be I'll be Tyson Chandler no
I'm DK I'm Dirk I'm sorry I'm Dirk was
Paia on that team you Jason Terry n no
he would but he was on one of those
teams that didn't but yeah not Jason
Terry well you gotta be Jason kid he
ends up being the coach one of the
greatest point guards of all time and
that's Jason Terry Jason Terry six man
in I like that yeah [__] upsetting
LeBron so talk to me about 600 obviously
Rose uh going crazy you guys have been I
feel like y'all dropped so much music
like and what's crazy is we haven't we
haven't we don't only we we've only
dropped what maybe four songs together
but like in the last like six months in
the last six months we've dropped still
two it's two and then your project is
obviously not a full project it's like a
EP yeah that was just that was just a
little something on some I really had
just been telling my team and I ain't
dropped in so long right I got to drop
something and we had just went to
Phoenix we was out there in Phoenix for
like two oh yeah you guys were at there
Airbnb out there recording cooking up
being racially
profiled yeah we ain't even going to
speak on that though you know we had
better times you know but uh either way
go yeah we made a bunch of bangers then
so I just decided to put some of them on
a little EP just thank God you did cuz
one your biggest records so far is on it
right yeah for show and you know it's
crazy I actually dropped that song
before the EP even came out it kind of
was just like a build up to the EP and
they didn't want me to drop it oh no we
didn't we didn't have enough time to uh
promote it set everything up for it I
said [__] that we got to do something
yeah they they they beging for it and so
I'm curious czy like uh are are you
still with United Masters still inde
theend is that is that something that
you ever are going to entertain cuz
everybody lot people been asking me that
they want to give you I'm I'm sure
there's a big out there for if you want
it but it just got to it got to make oh
what comes with that you know like what
comes with the bag cuz you go get a bag
No Matter What obviously my manager just
called one of my managers just called me
yesterday asked me the same question I
told him look as long as I still got the
the better half of my masters cuz I
don't care about the The Upfront Bay cuz
I the advance is short minded money
exactly I don't care about that I need
to know that at the end of the day I can
for one buy myself out MH and for two
that I have the majority of my man I
think I think he said 21 Savage is uh
who who 21 Savage was with
Brandon EP it's a 9010 you see what I'm
saying like that's great and it's like
that makes sense yes he got a 910 he has
a 910 good for him but it's like he went
with he went that's how he beat he beat
that immigration charge he had all that
money to spend on him he had the upper
hand when he went into that so like I
probably can do that right now but it's
like now I'm looking at a bigger picture
you know what I'm saying so I'm really
looking for they gotta give you the
label exactly they got to bring the
label over and so that's what we're
trying to do right now if if something
come my way and and and it makes sense
then cool but if not this is my focus
right now well I was going to ask for
you like uh what is obviously being on
the road with him working with him so
much when is your next body of work
going to be coming uh see we got the
tape coming out so sh we I'm on there
joint tape yeah 600 tape so oh it's
going to be like a compilation like a
label comp meet the Sixers oo meet the
Sixers you guys pay homage to a lot of
teams that aren't the
Mavericks but it's no it's not even the
team I know I know I'm just [__] with
you 600 I get I get it I'm just but it's
like an alternate ego like we since
we've been on the road man it's just
been some crazy ass moments going y got
to get that merch looking good man I
just got the logo and everything made
it's on the way it's on the way but yeah
man that's that's all I was the ego and
so it's just I don't know I just feel
like it's a lot of different flavors
between the three of us and so it just
it got crazy on every song we do how
long have you been working with the new
guy here that you brought I've been
working with hood you know what's crazy
we never did a song I I met Hood when I
met uh K okay so like whenever I started
going to the studio I was going to he
would he was always there and I done
heard him he was just freestyle like
even when he went to record it's just
freestyle s like the dude can make a
song in 5 minutes I never I never wrote
nothing y'all Texas boys can rap off the
top of your [__] head bro oh yeah man
that's the culture and so just seeing
that I always see I always told him I
think maybe our second conversation I
said man listen I I understand you got
going what you got going you making
money that's overto stood right but
[__] if I ever get enough money I'm
going [__] with I'm going sign you yeah
and the [__] was like I don't care
about no money like you come like you
you opportunity that's all I that's all
I want is opportunity I don't I ain't
never ask for no hand up but just to be
in front of the people that you're in
front of I feel like I could capitalize
off of it and that's what I'm here for
I'm yeah I'm opportunity that's why
brought road with me this o too much
opportunity out here I I'm getting mine
come get yours you know what I'm saying
so I think uh what also has been dope
about like the last couple of years of
like Texas hip hop is I feel like a lot
of like specific spefically just Dallas
like you guys are kind of spearheading
like obviously you're Affiliated you rap
about it we know what you know what I'm
saying but at the same time like I feel
like you guys are also kind of moving
with like an energy that is positive out
of the city and it doesn't feel divisive
it doesn't feel driven you know yeah
right now Dallas is on some getting
money like right now the it's it's
literally like a hash new Dallas is what
they doing right now # new Dallas and
it's just a bunch of getting money music
like everybody talking about there's
enough money for all
exactly and everybody finally seeing
that and so now it's just it sounds so
good in the city the city's so peaceful
right now that's beautiful crazy was
that kind of for you cuz I do feel like
I see it happening with uh with other
guys in Texas that are bubbling like you
know I've noticed like with a guy like
OT people in his City are starting to
hate on him cuz he's doing big [__] you
know what I'm saying like for you are
you very careful about being like too
overly exposed when you're at home
because I feel like you get the most hey
even if you don't even know it while
you're while you're at the crib is that
something that you deal with my managers
hated I'm outside every day you just
outside every
day every day because it's like I got to
this point by doing that showing my face
being in these clubs getting these songs
played letting people know that yeah I'm
here but I'm still y'all like I'm ain't
no difference I'm still the same ex
whatever and so I'm big on that and so
I make sure they there with me because
it's like this the steps I took to get
here so just let's just follow these
steps and see if it work for y'all too
so I'm outside every day though so uh
how you guys feeling about the Cowboys
end of the
season you know I'm Cowboy ain't going
to speak on you're not a Cowboy fan
right I'm still just let it ride you're
a Texans fan right which is so Random
yes Siri now my mom's from Houston no I
know it's still random it's not like
it's like it's not like the Texans have
been there forever you know I was a big
whole new [__] team the [__]
Oilers you yeah yeah you're right so um
bro uh Mike McCarthy
St oh don't know they I really thought
they were really about to bring bellich
Che in that [__] or har looking no
they're not oh they did they're keeping
they did damn they so did do you like
feel as a Cowboys fan like
um like you made bad choices in life to
get there like you know what I mean like
no
cuz like cuz like how old are you 26
yeah like you don't even remember them
being in the Super Bowl or winning so
like you're just it's just pain for you
it's like it's like butt fumbles and
like Jason Garrett and like and see and
that's why I could be a Cowboy fan do
you remember the butt fumble do you
remember that no oh see exactly cuz
you're yeah I he remember is Dez CAU it
Dez shout out to Dez he did Kat it but
that's that's that's as far as his
remembrance go no it don't how far it go
to you tonight
95 and I wasn't even born I felt
it5 my daddy was thinking about me when
they was at the Super Bowl yeah I mean I
don't know man I just this year was
rough I was like yeah like Dak Prescott
it's the same thing Green Bay is our
Kryptonite yeah everyone's your
Kryptonite in the playoffs n n no
literally the whole league no hey the
playoffs hit dax's like I got [__]
super commercials to film bro y you know
what I'm saying I'm out you know got to
go get these hips loose long as the
Eagles don't make it we good Jerry Jones
just needs to die which is going to
happen soon I'm sure but he's just gonna
pass it to his son well I mean I think
his son would have fired Mike
McCarthy I think it's the Jerry Jones
curse cuz he's kind of like he's kind of
like he's racis is you
know we don't think Jerry Jones is
racist he a little racist I don't know I
ain't never met him I I bet he love
black women yeah I bet he does you know
what I realized about the south y I
remember when they CAU him
here you like like I know Dallas doesn't
have like a big college for football
does it no is it SMU but SMU is not like
Powerhouse but in the South you got TCU
TCU too I was talking to Fredo bang and
we're talking about LSU football and I
was like man I feel like the one thing
college football does is it makes racist
people not racist on Saturdays yeah yeah
definitely for sure it's crazy
[__] would be racist magging
the [__] out and as soon as them [__]
black dudes put on them uniforms they're
[__] you know they they
L that [__] is crazy man so how uh how
far along are you with obviously when's
the compilation coming let's drop in mid
of mid of next month okay so you want to
they want to partner with it they want
to push it so we're going to allow them
to do that just you three on it uhh nice
mhm and then your new album
album being worked on yes sir I mean
it's really it's really D there done we
just you know we're going to give it
time to get cleaned up sharpen any
features outside of the guys
here
uh stop looking at Kyle man he he left
he's oh there he is can I tell him give
me one Kyle come on [__] a big one or or
or give me a big one mediocre give me a
mediocre one that's crazy medre hey cuzz
he's whoever he's about to say next yeah
me look look me I be big and Kevin Gates
yeah [__] Kevin Gate's going to try to
get y'all to work out you know that
right you know surprisingly he didn't
try to get me to work out not one time
on the tour he is so just he's [__]
he would do he would do little stuff
like uh I be like yeah man he like you
tired I be like yeah man I'm a little
tired he said you know that's because
when you eat all that
food you got to digest it them it's so
much food that you got to go to sleep
just to digest it you got your body got
to shut down to so he'll do little stuff
like he give you some education he try
to give you any supplements no or like
uh cuz he's got like uh a few
supplements he uses like uh not like
like steroids but like uh like natural
stuff you ain't never had an interview
of course I was going to say we talked
about this plenty him and I talk about
his health and his yoga like uh did he
try to get you to convert to Islam No No
he he was cool man he anytime you see me
show love I'm talking about he could be
on stage perform he see me he walked to
the side of the stage he's great yeah
yeah yeah we uh we're supposed to do an
interview next week so his new album is
coming so I make sure I ask him I'm
going to say hey you don't forget you
got to do that verse for for big X I'mma
see him today I'm going to his he got a
album release oh I'm going be there too
that's today's the 19th you wearing a
suit oh [__] it is today
[__] my kids got a game tonight I might
not be what time is it I'm supposed to
go I'm on the RSVP I think red carpet is
like 7 through 8 I think at 12 I'll be
there at 10:00 wait do you are you
supposed to wear a suit it said all
black Affair I think his team is wearing
suits but it's like I'mma have a pro
club on what is that just a black black
te you sound like my [__] manager
yeah it's black all black you say what
kind of black [__] I [__] yeah you you
ever have any issues getting into places
cuz you like to be shirtless nope I
bring that up because I believe you
tried to go to my clev and Scottdale and
my my coowner wouldn't let y'all in cuz
I feel like you were I feel like
somebody told me y'all try to get into
the club and they they shut y'all down
for dress code it might not have been my
spot I might have been pretty pleased
but one of the spots out we went to was
it the strip CL yeah yeah yeah it was
the strip CL when I had to put something
on my white
te yeah that that was him he had a white
T-shirt on did y go to Jaguars yeah JS
that's a great place oh it was there no
I did try to walk in there with my
jacket unzip they made me zip it up
Jaguars and then they didn't have no
they didn't have no liquor after no they
had Li they had oh they had the pour for
us yeah they had in Arizona that's a law
you got lock the bottle that [__] me
up see y'all got the Bob in Texas yeah
which is sick but [__] not I that club's
closing that two [__] really [__]
everything up in the city cuz wasn't
Dallas open late yeah till 5 oh damn now
you got to wait till Saturdays so why'
they do that just too much violence in
stri club yeah um and that's is is it
Onyx that's still popping out there
ecstasy be jumping Ecstasy but that's
where all
the Dominican Republic women that's
where I'd like to go yeah yeah Latin
women are my I don't like the you want
dance
babies you don't like the you want dance
baby you want dance
baby trust me I
knowbody yeah you want that baby you
want dance baby if you say anything
other than yes they going to pull their
phone out with a translator on
it happened too many times hey the worst
is when you go to the strip club and a
[__] just like don't get it don't get
the get the Clue the hint like hey don't
don't sit down like a [__] just sit on
your lap oh no I'm like hi we just went
to the strip club last night see I'm
Different I I get all my people in we
get our bottles in then they literally
it's like a little for some some reason
it's always a little block off and they
just be piled up right there and it's
just like you go
fishing you got your wristband just kind
of just dip it in the in the in the
ocean until one of them grabing before
you leave La you guys should go to Sam's
Hof bra it's downtown somebody told us
to go there so Sam's is the only strip
club I've ever been where all the girls
who aren't giving lap dances
that's I would say let's say they I
think they do 8 to 10 women at a time on
the middle stage uhhuh so let's say you
see a [__] and you like her but and you
make it rain on her uhhuh every girl on
that stage has a right to that dollar so
when you make it rain it's like feeding
pigeons at the park they just start
[__] bro they just start scrambling
to grab the money all at once it's fun
we got to go there it's like fun cuz
like I'm like I don't like to Make It
Rain usually but there I'm like you guys
see something funny
and then they all just
like it's great well what what race like
with with they got a nice a nice mixture
nice mixture yeah that might be to play
tonight then pH I'm just not into white
women so there's no white women there
that's you ever heard of crazy girls
yeah of course that's where that's where
we went crazy girls is a good place
those would be the two places I'd send
anyone who comes from anywhere crazy
girls and Sams see somebody tell us to
other place but it just sound like it
was giv saloon doors for sure but they
got good food good music is balloon
doors it's more like old school but it's
like great music DJ's fire always and
the food is smacking hot wings are good
there oh they got food yeah see crazy
girls don't have food they don't you got
to go outside you got to
suffer go to Wendy's across the street
and then after 2:00 you you got to pour
your bottles in water bottles yeah the
other day they [__] everybody up and
put in the apple juice bottles everybody
thought they had some good ass apple
juice what's your are you on the tequila
when you guys go out is it all tequila D
Julio
42 I need it I'm booing now on my tour
that's I got two of them on my rider so
you won't drink Patron oh yeah you know
what's crazy is when I was growing up
like in my day Patron was that hot [__]
cuz that's what all the rappers rapping
about you used to think it was some
high-end [__] but now you drink Patron
that [__] tastes like gasoline compared
to this new [__] they got like KAS
Amigos is so [__] smooth bro like
yeah R anything rip yeah yeah anything
rip I drink
but that that clear sh that's gasoline
can you give me you guys are have so out
here we have In-N-Out Burger you guys
have in Out Burger yet yeah okay I don't
know some places don't have in it out I
didn't even know roast people was crying
when they brought them hoes to
Texas I mean your guys' thing is Water
Burger which is all right yeah go crazy
water B go crazy water bger is better
than interet you know very Qui
facts facts waterburger okay I'm not
talking about the fries I'm talking
about Burger to Burger in- and- out is
water a burger or be in- and- out burger
especially if you eat it hot if you eat
it hot Burger to Burger water a burger
is wi off rib the burgers bigger that's
for one for two y'all are [__] crazy
the only thing I Ariz we got both the
only thing Inn out got on waterburger is
the line let me the line move faster a
nobody there thing about waterburger is
the only thing they have is the spicy
ketchup that spicy spicy ketchup is a
game changer and they used to have the
A1 thicking Hardy Burger they I was
going to say it it's not there anymore
yeah they don't have it they got that
that hatch green chili burger I do like
the the toast sandwich with the three
chicken strips and the barbecue sauce
with the white piece of cheese and I do
like the breakfast taquitos listen I I
don't know if you guys noticed or not I
[__] now name how many things you like
on in and out everything it's Burgers
and Fries Burg the sh the shakes are
better from water Burger I'm not talking
about shakes we talking about everything
the burger is smacking no bro you're
[__] crazy what you put onions like a
burger right of course e you don't like
onions on your burger
EO so give me your top five fast food
chains
period Chicken Express I don't even know
what that is oh my
God what you don't know what Chicken
Express is Chicken Express is only tast
what is Chicken Express don't worry
about it I'mma put you on
crazy is it like hey is it like Raising
Canes n no all right what I say what I
say already Chicken Express Chicken
Express I'mma say uh Raising
Canes okay I'mma say shout out to the
cane sauce I'mma say uh
uh f
you would think I was fatter than this
right no comment you said it you said it
not
me a Chipotle I wouldn't consider that
uh fast food but I I'll give it to you
it's not fast food I feel like fast food
has to have a drivethru drive the rule
is it has to have a
drive-through some of them do have
drivethru the [__] kind of Chipotle
y'all got in Texas
bro yeah got a drive through that's
[__] crazy Chipotle
Chick-fil-A okay what I got one more but
you just did all chicken bro that's all
we have you just did all chicken bro
what else do we have fast food y'all
ain't got [__] Wendy's out there y oh
Wendy's that's the McDonald's we don't
eat McDonald's that we watched my
manager almost [__] on this on tour off
of eating three chicken
nuggets I've been telling them to stop
eat McDonald's the only thing McDonald's
got is they fries I go there and get the
largest Fri I'm trying to stop drink
their MC chicken that H fresh for sure
the spicy hot and spicy McChicken I
ain't going lie to you put fries on the
chicken sandwich if we just on the road
and it ain't nothing for another 50 m i
get I get that but I'm so water BG is
not even in your top five you put
Wendy's over water bger that's crazy you
know what's crazy I take that bag Water
Burger is definitely better than Wendy's
yeah cuz I take a water B Burger over a
Baconator oo that's exactly what I get
from that too I don't know it's a draw
you put your fries in your
Frosty yeah you might be you might be
you might be a little thick and Hearty I
got I got the little Pono popping wait
wait wait you've never done french fries
in the
frosty guys guys guys guys guys guys
guys I got you it's the only reason like
when you go to Wendy's that's the
highlight of the time put the highlight
of the time is 4 for
four yeah 4 for four is good they [__]
the game when they did that I ain't
going to lie you to choose if you want
your nugget spicy or regular spicy nug
come on man [__] the game is good that's
the only with the $5 biggie bag yeah hey
the 4 is the only place holding on to
like old school prices for sure like
look if you're struggling you can still
come to Wendy we got you that's like an
Arizona that going to stay 99 cent no
it's not it's like 107 now that's for
tax yes 107 does it say 107 on the can
that's random no I say 99 on the can
yeah it's say 99 on the can but
it's damn but it used to just be 99 y
got Jack in the Box in Texas yeah but
Jack in the Box dir well this the thing
about Jack in the Box I ain't going to
lie that snack box for sure that snack
this my thing about Jack in the Box it's
like Old Faithful no matter what there's
one nearby and it's always open you know
what I never had from Jack In The Box
them tacos what them tacos is them hoes
he C he C is Nast he C you remember we
went out one time and we was
never had them though he gave me some of
his tacos huh bro cuz they look soggy
what you do the he he we kep no I'm not
no I'm not you got to get you want to
know the secret to Jack In The Box you
always order when no sauce because then
they have to make the taco Fresh So you
say let me get tacos no sauce all right
then they make new ones why and then you
get then you get extra taco sauce in the
bag and then you load [__] up but why
would you dip it in ranch dip the taco
in the ranch It's [__] amazing why
would you get a taco from a burger spot
I don't [__] know is it a burger spot
it's a burger spot is a burger SP it's a
burger spot is it though they got egg
rolls there bro they you feel me and
they got a chicken bowl bro and they got
breakfast sandwiches that's and they got
a breakfast burrito that's an
interracial spot it's interracial it's
for
everybody they have two Asian items on
the menu too they have a teriak bow and
they got egg rolls they got CH roll too
and they got CH they got [__] CH
roll they got they got cheesecake bro
you know you love cheesecake tacos
though from a burger spot they don't
even make sense but you'll go get a
burger from there though right it's a
burger spot how you know it's a burger
spot cuz it got Burgers but they push
tacos 99 Cents man come on Jack Jack
don't discriminate bro they not 99 Cents
no more either they like 127 yeah they
think they're 129 that's like going to
Wings Stop is sayy hey let me get a uh
triple cheeseburger they don't got them
they don't have that they have chicken
they have chicken they have I'm saying
that's what it's like no that's called
I'd like to point out that place is
called Wing Stop Jack in the Box isn't
called Burger in the Box it's called
Jack in the Box that means he's a jack
of all trades a jack of come on is on
[__] a jack of all menu items huh and
I don't we can't stand for the
McDonald's McDonald's disrespect won't
be tolerated it's the best yeah is
amazing I don't give a [__] what y'all
say McDonald's is amazing McDonald come
in handy it's it's smacks it used to be
amazing give me
the the breakfast is
hidden the
Sprite I don't drink s is the orange
High SE back Orange High it never left
[__] out hear it left Dam D they got rid
of that [__] and then they brought it
back cuz they were like there was so
much I don't think you guys notice it
left it left for about a year got it
taste I ain't really been eating
McDonald I just start back eating it
because we've been on the road but I be
struggling to eat it on the road I get
maybe a six piece nugget two hiot and
spices large fry sweet tea I get the
number nine two cheeseburgers what's the
number nine two just two normal
cheeseburgers then I get the hot and
spicy on the side so I got three
sandwiches uhhuh I put fries in all
three sandwiches oh I get a large Coke
so what's y best burger spice out
here and
also there's a place called Easy Street
Burgers that's amazing in North
Hollywood they actually Keith Lee just
went there and said it was the best
burger he ever had hey is Keith Lee from
Texas I don't know where the guy on Tik
Tok I don't know where he from I think
he's from Texas I think he's from
Houston oh Keith Lee he's the guy who
like is uh he does all the Tik Tok food
reviews he just went to the Bay Area and
and uh they're not happy with him cuz he
left early I mean like you supposed to
have snacks I thought you to have snacks
this time me
I got Edibles you want some
edibles there's some snacks here let's
do it here have some gummies do they
taste like candy though they taste like
appleberry nectar I'm scared you should
be just take those for here here those
are for you shout out to Munchies we
getting
hot you
know this guy over here was like yo you
guys got any weed I said I got some weed
what is his I see what you said yeah
whether or it's good he put that
[__] down it's another
discussion it's
weed but I would smoking
personally um what what what do you got
cooking over there man you obviously how
long have you guys been working together
now uh we've been around for over a year
now okay um so uh I already had [__]
going you I had some ice shout to him
little
German V
right before I had uh just dropped
croptober too I got you say croptober
croptober oh you're you're a
Bist I like that time of the year you
guys do any botney when he was over at
the shipping place well onew
punch I sniffing around you know what
I'm saying this uh on there I got S
Walker Hot Boy West um B on
there um Simo run
um who else I'm missing one more person
but um man like I just been working man
like U I got a a lot already invested so
bro like he was just seeing me like one
for the one for that right you know what
I'm saying so like I told him you know
what I'm saying when it before it even
happened I heard it you know I'm saying
like I said we both recording you got to
be 2 feet in man he he a he a room on B
room you know what I'm saying and I'm
telling bro like that [__] hard you know
what I'm saying like that [__] going go
like especially when he did Texas cuz
went back to the roots mhm and that's
why sauce always win he keep us Texas
you know saying they love us you know
what I'm say well I I think too like uh
y'all really never really went nowhere
it's just people were doing the sound
like you know what I think of like some
some records like people been sampling
or doing the not even sampling just
doing y'all style for so long and
getting credit for it you know what I'm
saying and then I think people forget
like hey Megan's from Texas Travis from
Texas you know post
Malone you know have you met post yet
through the Fone year oh nice yeah you
know who I met who Morgan Walling how
was that he's fire it was a time it was
a time what's it like hanging with him
what y'all
do I was uh he came to one of my shows
oh he did so he was he's just [__]
with you yeah yeah cuz he's tapped in on
the hip-hop [__] people don't know Texas
really did it for
me that took me Every Which Way but yeah
uh he pulled up to one of the shows he
was a dug hunting in where was we at
Arkansas where was we at
Arkansas so he popped up to one of the
shows he we got drunk y got [__] up
yeah he was already [__] up right but
then I popped open at 42 M it took us to
a whole another level any Edibles
involved
uh no a here yeah but no not there no it
was good y got y y got y'all got lit and
uh and had a good time so like he's like
the biggest country [__] star of the
last I don't know how many years Drake
of country he's the Drake of country so
would you guys work together we actually
cooking something up man really yeah
that's big so I got something I I got
something coming with Morgan wall I got
something coming with post Malone m
I got something coming with Morgan wall
and post
Malone check you out man I just hope
that you know uh you don't forget about
the little people I'm the little
people in this situ not quite literally
yeah well amongst those three you
wouldn't be the little
guy I mean how T
postone he like six I think he like six
we're about the same height yeah he's
about 6 feet yeah I thought he was T
than person so he's cool for sure yeah
you should tell him how you're a Houston
Texans fan though he he knows that I
almost lost I almost lost the feature
off of that yeah is there shouldn't be a
rivalry different [__] conferences
one team's brand new I just feel like we
should just Embrace each other like
especially after we win the Super Bowl
the Texans are like Teslas and like the
Cowboys are like uh for
Pinto that's [__] up that's real
[__]
up okay maybe not a pinto okay I ate two
of them you got to eat two you know what
the C the Cowboys are like like a 2010
Camaro that your homie who still sells
weed is driving and he you know he's
driving it like it's still 2010 you know
what I'm saying like he got some rims on
it but the ri hey hey hey he got a
little he got three three good rims and
a dut on the back right and all the rims
are scratched cuz he can't park that's
the
Cowboys that's [__] up yeah hey can
one of y'all hear me another one of them
Waters I'm promoting the brand hey this
K hard who is z
team no
no I'm I'm an Arizona Cardinal fan so I
actually know what it's like to be uh in
the depths of Hell on the football
fandom sir I got a Texas boy over there
though Kyler Murray yeah he should come
home to the Cowboys should come home so
you that that would be crazy do you want
to get rid of Dak I mean d be bull
hitting in the playoffs yeah it's the
hips y have you guys met CD lamb yet
we've seen all of them at the club at
the
club you cuz you don't care I would DJ
and the Cardinals would be there the
night before a big game at my club do
you know how [__] pissed I'd be cuz
I'd be like y got a game tomorrow bro
there's a [__] game tomorrow and you
know what's crazy that's I heard there
was a couple players at the at the club
of this P game right before and that's
what happened
cuz they be in there loose I didn't seen
D with his shirt but D went crazy Dak
shirtless in the club yeah that went
crazy oh yeah that that sound that
sounds about
right we seen Jamal Adams in there
too yeah we don't see no he from he I
think he from
Carolton he went to school in Carolton
but yeah you see jayen what jayen rer
rer wait wait wait wait no no he was the
guy who was on the Eagles mhm I was
thinking of rugs the guy who got into
that accident on the
Raiders oh yeah that was rough rip to
those folks um all right so uh has there
been anything uh for you that you've
noticed like because things are getting
bigger for you right like are you are
you becoming it's like hard for you to
like go like whatever City you're in go
to the store go to the mall like uh like
out of state n it's you know I you got
your couple people here there but in
Texas it's over for you yeah I can't go
to Walmart without taking like 30
pictures that's crazy you're still going
to Walmart huh yeah well I mean when I'm
at home at home no we just order it and
N I pick it up yeah Walmart's a wild
place in Texas yeah people who don't
know man [__] Southern Walmart's bro
something different
yeah
Wally you ever back in the day when they
were 24 hours you remember that yeah see
they just stopped they stopped doing the
pic that's what I'm saying like when I
was a kid we used to just get [__]
bored and just [__] kick Walmart 3 my
granny's so mad that's when she do her
her best shopping yeah they people be
thinking like oh I could get some
shopping done but then there's some
stupid ignorant High drunk [__]
in there riding around in the [__]
handicap
scooters my granny always thought that
that's when the um the freshest products
was out and then I [__] be in there
on a bike you know what I'm saying you
go to the bike section get on that
[__] bike don't let them have
one of them big ass baskets full of
basketballs in the middle of the [__]
toy area you turn into the [__] globe
trowers in there get your' goddamn ass
off the Box yeah can't forget you Donuts
shitut eat get a whole meal and yeah6
though you said chicken and donuts
simultaneously what you talking about
rotisserie the slurping machine was just
right you had Ranch Wings Ranch Wings
I've had wings
no
missing it you got to come kick it with
us for a day hey man I try I I go to
Walmart you know every every now and
again I've graduated in life to be a
Target guy you know we going go to
Target high as [__] Target high than the
beit and it's harder to it's harder I'll
be in Walmart like
[__] harder for what I don't know they
cameras is just extremely hard Ste yeah
yeah yeah man yeah Walmart they don't
care but you know what though what
Walmart does have if you're trying to if
you're trying to steal Walmart has the
guy checking your receipt at the door
Target don't have that that [__] do not
work but but they have a guy they have
like a line of defense there as where
Target you just walk
out now what if I know him oh the the
receipt guy or you just if I know the re
guy what if I what what if when I walk
in I say hey I got $100 for you if you
let me you know what I'm saying I used
to steal uh sports cards and magazines
and and what else did I steal from
Walmart back in the day I don't know if
I go to Walmart and I get 15 items seven
of them items I'm not paying for self
checkout oh yeah we had this discussion
you go through self check it's your
employee discount cuz you're an employee
at that point you're doing their job you
feel me definitely hey definitely more
so you walking with that receipt as long
as you got a receipt they don't care
yeah back in the day we used to go to
the mall and [__] and
throw when baggy pants are popping you
should be able to throw like two pairs
of pants on under your regular jeans and
go sell them like [__] expensive ass
jeans so like Lucky jeans or whatever
the [__] little shoplifter never hurt
nobody I still sometimes I'll steal now
bro I be hey don't let me be standing in
line at a gas station on a road trip
it's Weir I'm like listen him he's the
the worst influence cuz it don't matter
how much money he got he's forever gonna
take something out he not paying for
nothing out the gas station so you steal
everything out the gas station to I
ain't stole a day in my life okay so you
borrow
stuff I
borrow you'll be in the middle of
nowhere on a road trip but you guys
probably on tour you get out there's
[__] two ladies working maybe one
lady working you got care how many
people the easiest [__] is you're
looking at some [__] and you're like man
don't care how many people working I'll
just buy water and and put you know put
50 on pump 12 and cuz we already know he
be using us as decoys cuz he'll do some
[__] like what like he'll stand right
behind us while we paying and then when
we walk out he just walk out with
us or well I done paid and I'm sitting
here waiting on somebody he just toss
the [__] in my bag you ever put anything
under the cart during self checkout that
way you can kind of say like a I forgot
that was under there like you might be
pushing like I always put some [__] like
I like I never pay for my packs of water
I'm a fake skin I can like
you think it's scaming no no I [__]
around make the noise be I don't pay for
water I just always just I don't remind
them that it's on the bottom of my
[__]
cart you ever go to Costco and eat
samples Costco I a went to Costco since
I was selling candy in school you got to
go now I know you got a new house right
uhuh you got to populate that [__] with
some good old food Costco's the spot and
then you can just walk around all
[__] day see I'm blessed I'm blessed
yeah my old we I got kids so we still
get food
steps still got the EBT what that nice
three kids three kids everything's under
her name come on man you got to know how
to play it
hey hey just know I'm eating
good ladies and gentlemen uh I'm F to
order food day and then you know you can
order the food on Walmart with the EB
yeah oh [__] she order
up you know what's crazy we were just in
uh Utah you guys were just there we're
out there with the NBA young boy and our
boy Mustafa he's got two kids three kids
and every time we'd go somewhere like
the gas station he'd be like yo I got it
bro and I'm looking at him like nah bro
like it's cool I got it he's like no I
got it he's like I got to spend these
food
stamps and I'm like oh well in that
case what can we get at this
amm they got they got hot dogs let's get
a hot
dog [__] um all right so uh compilation
coming next month M uh you got the
project out right now uh singles going
crazy right
now um I you've had success at Radio
before Texas is gold or platinum
now uh I think it's D near
Platinum Platinum um but like I feel
like this record I see the way it's
moving up on the radio chart too I think
it's already go we just waiting on the
the uh what is it the Raa certification
go there you go yeah yeah well congrats
man and then you uh and uh you guys got
the 600 compilation coming yes sir
that's going to go
crazy I'mma play you one song like
whenever this all just how you it's
called the Sixers welcome to the meet
the Sixers are you guys going to have
some six looking
merch of course by the way I spent good
money on your Texas Ranger shirt not the
not the best quality the print
sucked the te was nice you that care
they fir the print was whatever but the
tea was really nice thick t-shirt good
t-shirt it was a bad DTG job I was like
you know what I [__] with this shirt
though I'm going to get one good wear
out of it cuz once it's washed it's a
wrap and I was right damn
cuz we
got no every about we just had a meeting
with who is that that we just had a
meeting with Brandon network network
that's what I'm going to be doing my
merch with now uh how excited like I
you're I mean you obviously [__] with
the Rangers were you excited you guys
beat my Diamondbacks in the World Series
I was in Texas at the time you know as
soon as they won you know what what song
you think played Texas yeah but I'm just
saying like were you a baseball fan like
that I didn't know I I threw the first
pitch that was my first time ever going
to a baseball game peeee how was how was
it was it good like a pitch did you get
it over the plate strike it was a strike
what I did good right was all bro he
always hating it was you could better
yeah it was straight it was 30 mes per
hour that's not fast but it was a curve
[__] like it but it was a strike cuz
you you remember when remember when 50
sent through that [__] and that [__]
went like oh yeah man I see it went
right to the hand right yeah I got
a were you at did you did you like do
sports or and I had my shirt on but oh
you were outside I was I was the first
person yeah on that baseball field with
that shirt on history I believe
you I ain't know I don't know nobody
else that I don't know I don't watch
baseball like that I but I threw the
first pitch with I had the Jersey on but
it was not but they tried to make me
Buton it well listen man I'm very uh
excited for you guys proud of you keep
killing it uh your Texans are still
alive shout out to CJ stoud have you dm'
him like Hey CJ thank you bro I don't
want to [__] up nothing don't [__] up so
I'm just going to let everything play
out and then when they do cuz they just
wanted me to come to the gamer and
perform at the little half time [__] but
I was I had a show so I could but I'm
just trying to stay the [__] up cuz
everything sports related that I've done
anything for they lost right so I'm just
trying to stay the [__] away have you
done something for the Mavs
yet uh
no that's probably why they de right now
how manyan
right the Cowboys they I'm like they
theme song they paid me to remix it and
some other [__] yeah uh the Rangers what
about the Stars they they like they play
it in the arena but it's like we ain't
got no do they still do like I just
watched this movie called The ironclaw
about the Von Erics which I've never
been to a a wrestling show is what I was
going to ask Oh I thought you was going
to say I was going to say wrestling cuz
it in Texas like I didn't realize in
Dallas it's like that's where the Von
Eric's there's a big movie out Zack eone
starring in it it's about this wrestling
family from Texas that was like the
worst luck ever but they're all from
Dallas there was a place called U the
sportatorium in Dallas back in the day
where they used to have these
independent wrestling shows where Stone
Cold came out came up man
y' ain't watching wrestling you still
watch wrestling not watch wrestling I a
watch wrestling since I was in like
Middle School yeah not tripping that
shit's fire I'm going to Royal Rumble
next week I I would go to a wrestl man
though I would CU it would piss me off I
would go to a wrestl nah bro cuz if you
went they'll [__] put you in the ring
and you'll be able to like do a move
they you'll lay somebody out but I'm but
I would still be mad cuz now I got to
fake the
move it don't matter it's all my S
effect is not the
best ah
you see you see Snoop Dog wrestling yeah
yeah you got to get on that that was
back there this [__] was last year
WrestleMania he wrestled I'm talking
about long time ago when he was on there
he's wrestled like 30 times Snoop Dogg
is the side quest King yeah he got a lot
of [__] going you'll be like what the
[__] what you see how he just did us
with the no smoking [__] yeah and all
time he was talking about a [__] G
and the guy I guess it didn't work for
the company so the CEO of that that
company just got fired because that
marketing idea probably cost them a
bunch of money to pay Snoop didn't
result in many stoves
sold all right so next time I'm going to
come to Texas we're going to go murder
some pigs let's do it and we're going to
go we're going to go eat um Chicken
Express yeah okay we're going to go get
Ranch wings from Walmart Ranch wings
from Walmart and we're going to get them
for free and I'm going to show you
how
okay so we're going to go we're going to
go steal um which I'm I'm comfortable
with we could Vlog it I mean and then
just drop it after like five years you
know uh and then uh I guess we'll go to
a Texans game oh we can't do that can't
do that's too far uh Cowboys game I
can't do that season's over huh take you
Rudy rud chicken okay you like chicken
yeah you like this I like Raising Canes
man going take n This Hood n Hood
chicken right here okay where they got
the little Ash on the elbow yeah and
it's like chickens have Ash on their
elbows the cook for sure got hat on his
elbow for sure yeah for sure well look
man I'll see y'all out there soon um
make sure you guys go support go stream
new music on the way and uh any videos
coming yeah we got a lot of videos
coming too many to even talk about would
you and yo ever do a project together
yeah I do a project with him feel like
you guys are [__] when you guys are I
just been so I've been busy we've been
talked about it this guy's busy man he
can barely even walk through a Walmart
anymore either because he's banned or
he's really famous and gets recognized
me one of the two it's the ble cat
podcast appreciate y'all man sir fire